.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
* Lässige E-Gitarren-Klänge *
Mein Vater gehörte als Kaminfeger
zur Zunft der Glücksbringer.
Überall wurden die Kaminfeger
in Berufsuniform gerne eingeladen.
Ihm selber aber
brachte sein Beruf kein Glück.
Hier ein Gläschen mit den Kunden
und dort ein Kafi-Schnaps
mit den Kollegen.
In den 50er- und 60er-Jahren
war es üblich,
dass man
während der Arbeitszeit trank.
Das wurde ihm zum Verhängnis.
In der Schule
war es halt einfach unschön,
dass, wenn man
ein Theater aufgeführt hat,
bei allen die Eltern kamen,
aber bei mir einfach niemand.
Wenn man dann gefragt wird,
warum das Mami nicht da ist ...
Was will man sagen?
"Sie ist jetzt zu Hause am saufen?"
Mit der Zeit merkt sie, wenn sie nur
ein Fläschchen getrunken hat,
dass es nicht mehr wirkt.
Dann braucht sie ...?
- ... eine zweite.
Genau. Und irgendwann braucht sie?
(Im Off) Wenn man von den Zahlen
von Sucht Schweiz ausgeht,
laut denen etwa 100'000 Kinder in
der Schweiz in einer Familie leben,
in der es ein Alkoholproblem gibt,
muss man davon ausgehen,
dass im Raum Winterthur etwa 2'500
Kinder in einer Familie leben,
in der es ein Alkoholproblem gibt.
Wenn man nun mal so rechnet,
dass gut ein Drittel dieser Kinder
ein Problem haben, müssten 800
Kinder bei uns in der Therapie sein.
Wir haben aber nur etwa 50 Kinder.
Über 40 Jahre ist es her,
seit mein Vater starb.
Er stürzte zu Hause
die Treppe hinunter.
Da er alleine wohnte,
blieb sein Sturz unbemerkt,
und er blieb mehrere Tage liegen.
Diesen Unfall überlebte er nicht.
Er wurde 47 Jahre alt.
Ich war knapp 16 und ich erinnere
mich, dass ich damals geweint habe.
Aber nicht, weil er gestorben war,
sondern weil es mir nichts mehr
ausmachte, dass er tot war.
Meine Mutter hatte ihn
zehn Jahre vorher verlassen.
Während all dieser Jahre
war er für mich ein Fremder geworden.
Auch die Kindheit
der heute 16-jährigen Magda-Lena
ist geprägt vom Alkoholkonsum
eines Elternteils.
Nach Suizidversuchen und einem Irrweg
durch Heime und Kliniken
ist sie vor drei Jahren
in einem sozialpädagogisch betreuten
Wohnheim im Kandertal gelandet.
Sie möchte sich vor der Kamera
nicht ganz offen zeigen.
Ganz am Anfang,
als ich hierhin kam ...
Also ich weiss noch,
ich war damals in der Geschlossenen.
Dann hiess es:
"Du kommst nach Kandersteg."
Kein Plan, wo das ist, und dann
sah ich: Es ist am Arsch der Welt.
Es hat einfach ... einfach nichts.
Mein Mami trinkt, seit sie mit mir
schwanger war. Oder schon vorher.
Das kann ich auch nur sagen, weil
ich eine vergrösserte Leber habe.
Sobald sie aufstand,
öffnete sie eine Büchse Bier,
und dann immer wieder,
den ganzen Tag,
sobald ihre Bierdose fertig war,
kam die nächste.
In der schlimmsten Zeit
kippte sie sich eine ganze
grosse Flasche Wodka allein rein.
Ich habe keine Erinnerung daran,
dass sie nicht getrunken hat.
Mein Papi ist schon ziemlich früh
gegangen, als ich etwa vier war.
Da hat er sich
eine andere Wohnung gesucht.
Und irgendwann habe ich
dann halt meinen Papi gefragt,
dann hat er gesagt,
dass es wegen dem Alk war.
Es ist schade, v.a., wenn man
fast jeden Abend im Bett liegt
und weint, weil man ihn nicht sieht.
V.a. weil ich früher
sehr ein Vaterkind war.
Pandabären sind Familientiere.
Sie sind viel beieinander,
sie geben sich Wärme.
Diesen Pandabären habe ich
eigentlich immer zum schlafen.
Früher habe ich mich
schon sehr, sehr geschämt für das,
was zu Hause ablief, denn
wenn ich bei anderen zu Hause war,
war immer
so schön aufgeräumt und so.
Die Eltern waren halt immer
ganz anders drauf als mein Mami.
Die Entbehrungen einer Kindheit
mit einem alkoholkranken Elternteil
können Menschen lebenslänglich
prägen. Davon erzählt mir Monika.
Ich bin in eine sehr, sehr arme
Familie geboren worden,
als drittältestes von acht Kindern.
Mein Vater hat getrunken,
er war Alkoholiker
und hat dafür viel Geld ausgegeben.
Deswegen hat es bei uns
einfach nie gereicht.
Wir mussten sehr häufig umziehen,
weil die Miete
nicht mehr bezahlt werden konnte.
Zuletzt landeten wir
in diesem alten Bauernhaus.
Die Stimmung war sehr bedrückt,
weil der Vater jeden Abend
betrunken nach Hause kam.
Er war aggressiv,
wenn er betrunken war,
er hat die Mutter immer geschlagen.
Wir schliefen im oberen Stock.
Ich ging einmal
oben zum Fenster raus
und kroch ans Schlafzimmerfenster,
um nachzuschauen,
was da drin passierte. Mein Vater
wollte meine Mutter erwürgen.
Ich habe dann
mit der Hand ans Fenster geschlagen,
da wurde er abgelenkt
und liess von der Mutter ab.
Ich rannte davon.
Meine Mutter
war überfordert mit uns Kindern
und wurde dann
auch uns gegenüber gewalttätig.
Sie hat einfach
ihre Wut an uns ausgelassen.
Ich hatte ganz schwere Zeiten
und niemanden zum reden,
aber an diesem Platz
fand ich Ruhe.
Es ist der See -
ich liebe das Wasser.
Und es ist der Baum. Ich glaube,
das war wie ein Schutz für mich.
Er umgibt einen. Es war auch
die Nähe zu Gott. Die Ruhe.
Ja,
einfach Frieden finden zu können.
* Ruhige, tiefe Klänge *
Bei der integrierten Suchthilfe
in Winterthur
treffe ich den Kinderpsychologen
Georg Kling.
Das therapeutische Angebot Zebra
fokussiert hier
ganz auf die Bedürfnisse
von Kindern und Jugendlichen.
Hier im Zebra
haben wir Kinder aus allen Schichten
und Altersstufen
von fünf bis 18 Jahren.
Wir haben auch viele Leute
in der Sozialhilfe,
aber durchaus auch Leute,
die aus sehr gut situierten
Verhältnissen kommen.
Das Malen ist bei uns
nicht therapeutisch,
sondern soll
eigentlich Spass machen.
Bei Kindern ist es einfach noch so,
dass es sehr schwierig ist zu reden,
wenn man sich gegenüber sitzt.
Ganz oft geht das Reden
auch allgemein nicht.
D.h., dann spielt man einfach
und versucht
eine Situation herzustellen,
in der man kommunizieren kann,
in welcher Art auch immer.
In Familien
mit einem alkoholkranken Elternteil
richtet sich die Aufmerksamkeit
auf den Süchtigen.
Die kindlichen Bedürfnisse
gehen vergessen.
Die Not dieser Kinder
steht bei Zebra im Vordergrund.
Heute ist Zoe bei Georg Kling
in Therapie.
Ihr Vater starb vor drei Jahren
an seiner Alkoholkrankheit.
Also schauen, was heisst das genau?
Meistens habe ich im Haus geschaut,
wo sie den Alkohol versteckt hatte,
und wenn ich ihn gefunden habe,
habe ich ihn ausgeleert
oder zu mir genommen.
Oder ich habe sie manchmal
auch darauf angesprochen:
"Du, Mami, hast du getrunken?"
Meistens hat sie Nein gesagt.
Da hat sie mir praktisch
ins Gesicht gelogen,
das hat mich jeweils sehr verletzt.
Manchmal habe ich auch gesagt:
"Hauch mich mal an!"
Das hast du auch gemacht?
- Ja.
Du hast ja noch anderes gemacht,
um dein Mami zu kontrollieren.
Was war denn das?
Ich habe halt versucht,
sie von sämtlichen Tankstellen
oder so fernzuhalten.
Ich habe mich sehr gesorgt,
dass sie in die Klinik kommt.
Wer kann eigentlich
deinem Mami helfen?
Es gibt eigentlich nur jemanden,
der deinem Mami
wirklich helfen kann, aufzuhören.
Wer ist das? Was würdest du sagen?
Keine Ahnung ... Einfach ...
Sie selber. Sie ist die einzige,
die es wirklich kann.
Du kannst es nicht und auch
die Therapeutin kann es nicht.
Sie kann ihr helfen,
aber ändern kann es nur sie alleine.
* Leise, unheimliche Klänge *
Nur ein Drittel aller Kinder aus
suchtkranken Familien schafft es,
ein Leben ohne Sucht und psychische
Beeinträchtigungen zu führen.
Das Risiko dieser Kinder,
selber suchtkrank zu werden,
ist sechsmal höher
als in gesunden Familienstrukturen.
Kinder, die von ganz klein auf in
extrem schwierigen Situationen leben
und z.B. auch Gewalt erleben,
haben oft schon selber
eine grössere Problematik,
auch psychische Problematik
in ihrem Leben.
Unserer Meinung nach
wird das oft sehr unterschätzt.
V.a. auch, was das für Auswirkungen
auf die Kinder hat.
Als meine Eltern heirateten,
wusste meine Mutter,
dass mein Vater zu viel trank.
Sie war aber überzeugt, dass sie ihm
helfen könne und er damit aufhöre,
sobald er Familie habe.
Ihre Bemühungen, ihn vom Trinken
abzuhalten, waren jedoch vergeblich.
Nach dem vierten Kind sah sie das ein
und überliess ihn seinem Schicksal.
Alleine rutschte er
immer tiefer ins Elend.
Die Trennung meiner Eltern ersparte
es mir und meinen Geschwistern,
den Zerfall unseres Vaters
aus der Nähe mitzuerleben.
Für Magda-Lena war es schwieriger.
Sie hielt die Situation zu Hause
nicht mehr aus.
Mit 13 habe ich mein Mami
vor die Wahl gestellt:
"Entweder ich oder der Alkohol,
sonst gehe ich."
Aus der Hoffnung heraus,
dass sie es so irgendwie checkt.
Dann fand sie nur: "Ja, dann geh."
In der Schule lief es nicht gut,
daheim lief es nicht gut.
Dann habe ich mich halt,
weil ich keinen Ausweg mehr fand,
versucht, mich umzubringen und so.
Ja.
Ich habe mich damals geritzt.
Das Blut zu sehen und das zu spüren,
hat mir irgendwie geholfen:
"Ich bin noch da. Ich lebe noch."
Das war nicht so schön.
Das erste Mal, dass ich trank,
war mit 13.
Es ist alles ein wenig verschwommen,
es war so eine Scheissegal-Stimmung.
Das hat mir nicht geholfen,
aber es war ab und zu einfach schön,
auf alles ficken zu können.
Die Zeit im Wohnheim half Magda-Lena,
ihre Situation besser zu verstehen.
Sie realisierte,
dass sie ihr Leben ändern musste.
Ich weiss noch,
das war in einem Sommer.
Da wollte ich eins rauchen,
sass da draussen auf dem Bänkli,
schaute in die Berge, dachte einfach
über alles mal nach und merkte:
"Ich will nicht werden
wie mein Mami."
Ich hatte auch schöne Momente
mit ihr.
Wenn wir mal zusammen zum Coiffeur
sind oder sonst einfach mal
in die Stadt, händchenhaltend
durch die Stadt gingen.
Das war schon schön.
In der Schule
wurde ich dann viel besser.
Ich habe jetzt auch
meinen Traumberuf als Automech,
ich habe eine Lehrstelle
als Automech bzw. Automobilfachfrau.
In einem halben Jahr
bin ich hier draussen,
dann mache ich eine WG auf. Die
ist zwar noch betreut, aber ... Ja.
Wir sind immer geplagt worden
in der Schule,
die Leute haben uns immer belächelt.
"Er ist ein Säufer
und sie ist nicht normal
und die Kinder sind noch schlimmer."
Dieses Ausgelachtwerden
war sehr, sehr schlimm.
Wir waren sehr verwildert.
Es hat sich niemand gekümmert
oder nachgefragt,
was wir machten oder wo wir waren.
Wir gingen einfach am Morgen und
kamen meistens am Abend wieder heim.
Einmal haben wir dem Vater
einen Hasen gestohlen
und haben den im Wald gebraten.
Der Bruder hat in geschlachtet,
ausgenommen, das Fell abgezogen.
Dann haben wir ein Feuer gemacht
und den einfach gebraten.
Ohne Gewürze,
wir haben den so gegessen.
Ich habe mich immer gefühlt
wie Pippi Langstrumpf,
der niemand
Vorschriften machen kann.
Einfach tun und lassen was man will
im Wald. Ja, das war einfach so.
Und am Abend kam das Grauen,
wenn wir wieder nach Hause gingen.
Das war in der 5. Klasse,
da habe ich die mal zerrissen,
weil ich mich selber hasste.
Ich habe mich geschämt,
dass ich überhaupt auf der Welt bin,
dass ich überhaupt da bin.
Ich habe mich geschämt
für meine Eltern, für meinen Vater,
dass er getrunken hat.
Ich habe immer gehört:
"Du bist so blöd, du bist so doof."
Ich hatte immer das Gefühl,
ich sei schlecht, ich sei böse,
darum sei mir das passiert.
Und das ist
ein schreckliches Gefühl als Kind.
Die allermeisten
denken das Leben lang,
sie seien irgendwie schuld
oder verantwortlich,
das kriegt man fast nicht weg.
Uns ist es ganz wichtig,
dass die Kinder Bescheid wissen,
was die Eltern
für eine Krankheit haben,
nämlich eine Suchterkrankung.
Das ist für die meisten Kinder
eine grosse Entlastung.
Was ist denn deine grösste Angst?
Dass meiner Mutter das Gleiche
passiert wie meinem Vater.
Kannst du mir nochmals erzählen,
wie das war,
als er gestorben ist und du gemerkt
hast, dass es wegen dem Alkohol war?
Eigentlich kam ich einfach von der
Schule nach Hause, hatte es lustig,
und meine Mutter sagte,
dass mein Vater gestorben sei.
Ich fragte dann
nach ein paar Minuten, wieso.
Da erzählte sie dir, dass es
wegen dem Alkohol war? - Ja.
Es hat, glaube ich, allen wehgetan,
auch meiner Mutter,
obwohl sie getrennt waren.
Meine Mutter und mein Vater
tranken einfach
Wein und Alkohol und alles.
Ich dachte natürlich,
das sei so,
wie wir Jugendlichen
Cola oder Eistee trinken.
Es seien halt
Getränke für Erwachsene.
Als dann mein Vater
an Alkoholproblemen gestorben ist,
habe ich erst realisiert,
wie schlimm es eigentlich ist.
Von da an habe ich
meine Mutter wirklich kontrolliert.
Nach dem Tod meines Vater
überlegte ich ganz viel.
Ich hatte auch das Gefühl,
ich sei schuld.
"Hätte ich doch etwas gesagt."
Aber ich war damals neun.
Wäre es dir eine Hilfe gewesen,
wenn man dir
viel früher gesagt hätte,
was dein Vater
für eine Krankheit hatte? - Ja.
Wenn das eine Krankheit ist
und das beide Eltern haben,
kann es sein, dass es bei mir
später auch ansteckend ist?
Also ansteckend ist es nicht.
Eine Alkoholabhängigkeit kann
nicht ansteckend in dem Sinne sein.
Was wir wissen, ist, dass Kinder,
deren Eltern eine Sucht haben,
ein grösseres Risiko haben. Die
bekommen häufiger auch ein Problem.
(Im Off) Ich würde sagen,
für Zoe sieht es recht gut aus.
Sie geht sehr offen und sehr direkt
mit diesen Schwierigkeiten um
und ist sehr interessiert,
Lösungen zu finden.
Ausserdem hat sie einen sehr guten,
gewinnenden Charakter,
das schützt Kinder
eigentlich auch oft.
Vielen Kindern merkt man das
schwierige Umfeld zu Hause nicht an.
Weil sie in Gedanken oft daheim sind,
gelten sie als unkonzentriert.
Oder sie sind überangepasst.
Diese Warnsignale werden
missverstanden oder ganz übersehen.
Wenn ein Kind in der Schule
gut funktioniert,
wird die Schule nicht reagieren.
Es passiert erst etwas,
wenn jemand aggressiv wird
oder im Winter Sommerkleider anhat.
Dann sieht man das
und kann auch reagieren.
In Monikas Familie
schaltete sich die Behörde ein,
als die Mutter für
eine weitere Geburt im Spital war.
Als wir noch klein waren,
musste unsere Mutter ins Spital,
sie hat das siebte Kind geboren.
Unsere älteste Schwester
hat uns dann mit dem Beil beschützt.
Sie stand die ganze Nacht
mit dem Beil in der Küche,
weil sie Angst hatte,
uns komme jemand holen.
Ich war fünfeinhalb Jahre alt,
als die Behörde kam
und uns voneinander trennte.
Ich kann mich erinnern, ich war
in einem Zimmer in einer Ecke.
Ich wollte mich einfach verstecken,
damit mich niemand sah.
Der Vater hatte
so eine Rolle Guezli und sagte:
"Die könnt ihr noch mitnehmen."
Ich durfte meine Mutter
noch einmal sehen,
bevor wir dann
in Pflegefamilien verteilt wurden.
Nach Jahren konnte ich ... im
Kinderheim die Unterlagenkopie holen
und da stand:
"Die Mutter
versteht nicht zu haushalten,
die Familie
musste aufgelöst werden."
Wie hätte meine Mutter haushalten,
wie hätte sie etwas machen können,
wenn kein Geld und nichts da war?
Das Hauptproblem,
dass es uns so beschissen ging,
war ja der Alkoholkonsum des Vaters.
Das war ja das Hauptproblem.
Vier Jahre später hat die Mutter -
gegen den Widerstand der Behörden -
Monika aus der Pflegefamilie
wieder zurück nach Hause geholt.
* Lockere Musik *
Wie geplant hat Magda-Lena
vor einem halben Jahr
ihre Lehre als Automobilfachfrau
begonnen
und ist vom Heim in eine WG gezogen.
Der neue Alltag
ist für sie eine Herausforderung.
Jeden Montag kommt eine Betreuerin
und jeden Donnerstag ein Betreuer.
Dann kochen wir zusammen
und bereden, wie es gelaufen ist.
Vorher war es eben so,
man hat mir alles nachgesagt,
man hat mir immer alles
irgendwie in den Arsch geschoben,
und jetzt heisst es einfach:
"Dann und dann, das und das."
"Wenn du daran denkst, ist gut,
wenn du nicht daran denkst ..." Ja.
Ich stehe jeden Tag um 5 Uhr auf,
damit ich um 7.30 Uhr anfangen kann,
weil ich einen Arbeitsweg
von 50 Min. habe.
Es ist schon vieles, das ich
irgendwie in den Griff kriegen muss,
aber irgendwie
bekomme ich es schon hin.
Auch der Start in ihre Ausbildung
ist in vielerlei Hinsicht
für Magda-Lena nicht einfach.
Am Anfang
hatte ich sehr oft Muskelkater.
Nur schon vom Autoputzen.
Wenn ich Autos gewaschen habe,
nur schon von dieser Bewegung
die ganze Zeit, hatte ich
hier in den Schultern Muskelkater.
Und ich hatte sehr oft Schmerzen,
auch an den Füssen,
weil ich es nicht gewohnt war,
den ganzen Tag zu stehen.
Wir behandeln sie nicht anders
als alle anderen Leute,
egal, was sie
für einen Hintergrund hat.
Sie muss die gleichen Sachen machen,
sie darf die gleichen Sachen machen
wie wir alle auch.
Meine Mitarbeiter und mein Chef
wissen nur,
dass ich eben aus diesem Heim komme.
Aber sonst ist meine Vergangenheit
eigentlich nie Thema
und ich will auch nicht
bemitleidet werden oder so.
Ich war bis vor fünf Jahren
50 kg schwerer als jetzt.
Das war für mich ein Schutzpanzer.
Es konnte passieren, was wollte,
es ist alles an mir abgeprallt.
Ich schob halt jeweils
noch eine Pizza mehr in den Ofen
und ass noch eine Pizza.
Ich habe mir
dieses schöne Kleid gekauft,
als meine Tochter
vor ein paar Jahren geheiratet hat.
Ich wollte auch mal dazugehören,
ich habe mich ja jahrelang ge-
schämt - immer dieser Minderwert.
Wenn ich das Hochzeitsbild ansehe,
dann schaudert es mich,
wenn ich sehe, wie ich aussah.
Das war mir gar nicht bewusst.
Ich war ja immer noch
die genau Gleiche, innerlich,
einfach äusserlich
in diesem schönen Kleid.
Einfach mal,
um den Leuten zu zeigen:
Ich bin auch jemand, und v.a.
kann ich mir das Kleid leisten.
Obwohl ich es mir
fast nicht leisten konnte,
es hat mir finanziell
fast das Genick gebrochen.
Irgendwo hat das gar nicht
zu mir gepasst vom Äusseren her,
aber innerlich
hat mir das sehr, sehr gut getan,
das war ein richtig fettes Pflaster
auf meine wunde Seele.
Zum schönen Kleid gehörten natürlich
diese wunderschönen Schuhe.
Da sind Glitzersteinchen dran.
* Perlende, melancholische Klänge *
Eine Suchterkrankung ist ganz oft
ein grosses Familiengeheimnis.
Wir erfahren schwierige Situationen
oft erst,
wenn es einen behördlichen Weg gibt.
Wenn es z.B.
einen Polizeieinsatz gab.
Und selbst dann
werden wir oft angelogen.
Sogar die Kinder erzählen oft,
alles sei in Ordnung,
und ich erfahre dann
von der Beiständin,
dass es drei Polizeieinsätze
wegen Gewalt in der Familie gab.
Als Erwachsener denkt man immer,
die Kinder müssten ihre Eltern
hassen dafür, was sie ihnen antun.
Das ist überhaupt nicht so,
die Kinder sind den Eltern gegenüber
immer extrem loyal.
Sie stehen zu ihren Eltern.
Wird die Not
für Kinder und Jungendliche zu gross,
bieten auch die Beraterinnen und
Berater der Stiftung Pro Juventute
über die Telefonnummer 147 Hilfe an.
Ah, okay. Ja.
Wir sind bei der Beratung
und Hilfe 147 24 Std. da, jeden Tag.
An Weihnachten, an Silvester.
Morgens um 2 Uhr.
Man muss sich nicht überlegen,
ob offen ist oder nicht,
man darf einfach anrufen.
Alle Angebote sind kostenlos
und es ist vertraulich.
Man muss nicht sagen, wer man ist.
Man muss auch nicht sagen,
wo man wohnt.
Wir haben jeden
Tag ein bis zwei Kinder,
die anrufen zum Thema
Alkoholsucht in der Familie.
Es kann sein,
dass ich einen Anruf entgegennehme
und es ist gerade
mitten in einem Konflikt,
ich höre im Hintergrund, dass
Eltern streiten, dass es laut ist.
* Spannungsvolle Musik *
Ich schaue dann auch, ob sich das
Kind zurückziehen kann ins Zimmer,
denn im ersten Moment ist
v.a. der Schutz des Kindes wichtig,
sodass es dieser Situation
nicht weiter ausgesetzt ist
und nicht Gefahr läuft,
verletzt zu werden.
Und dann höre ich wirklich mal zu,
was gerade vorgefallen ist.
Willst du die Türe mal zumachen?
Mhm.
Wenn ein Kind sich meldet,
das wirklich Suizidgedanken hat
oder schon Pläne
oder bereits Suizidhandlungen macht,
dann organisieren wir Hilfe vor Ort.
Wir haben natürlich
auch andere Gespräche,
leichte Gespräche,
lustige Gespräche.
Es muss sich ja
auch ein wenig die Waage halten,
denn die ganz schweren Gespräche,
die sind auch für uns
schwierige Arbeit.
Wir hatten zwar
ein schwieriges erstes halbes Jahr.
Sie hatte einfach
zu wenig Motivation.
Sie hat viele Sachen
als normal aufgefasst
und zu wenig Einsatz gegeben.
Zu wenig an dem gearbeitet,
wo sie Probleme hat,
und war einfach ein wenig da.
Das sind Dinge, die funktionieren
halt nicht im Berufsleben.
Ich habe nicht wirklich erkannt,
dass ich Gas geben sollte,
alles geben müsste und so.
Ich gab mir schon Mühe,
aber irgendwie reichte es nicht.
Das ist jetzt die Zündspule.
- Mhm.
Es tut ...
Ja genau, die Explosion, der Strom.
Der Strom wird hochtransformiert,
damit es ...?
Wir hatten zwei Gespräche.
V.a., als ich ihr klar machte,
dass das so nicht geht,
hat sie es realisiert.
Jetzt ist sie ganz anders.
Es ist cool, wie wir jetzt unter-
wegs sind, und ich glaube daran,
dass sie es schafft, in drei Jahren
die Abschlussprüfung zu meistern.
* Vereinzelte, melancholische Töne *
Es ist Donnerstagabend und Magda-Lena
hat Besuch von Darius Omlin,
ihrem Betreuer.
Mhm.
Was ist eigentlich
mit dem Scheibenwischermotor,
hast du den wieder mitgenommen?
Nein, ich habe ihn
immer noch in der Bude.
Aber ihr habt ihn
noch nicht laufen lassen,
um zu schauen,
ob er noch funktioniert?
Das wäre ja spannend gewesen,
nachdem wir ihn auseinandergenommen
haben, ob er noch funktioniert.
Da kam Magda-Lena am Anfang
ziemlich auf die Welt,
als ihr ihr Chef
nach zwei Monaten sagte,
dass ihr quasi jegliche Grundlagen
fehlen beim Schrauben,
in der Mechanik, der Materialkunde,
Werkzeugkunde usw.
Darum haben wir dann ein Kistchen
mit Werkzeug und Teilen organisiert
und versuchen jeden Donnerstagabend,
das aufzunehmen
und die Dinge, die ihr fehlen,
zu ergänzen.
* Lässige, lockere Klänge *
V.a. beim Gespräch, bei dem er
dir direkt ins Gesicht sagte:
"Hör zu, ich bin mit dir
nicht zufrieden und überlege mir,
dich zurückzustufen" ...
- Ja.
Da ist für dich
eine Welt zusammengebrochen. - Ja.
Ich war sehr traurig
und geschockt, so etwas zu hören,
denn ich hatte mir Mühe gegeben.
Aber irgendwie merkte ich:
Es ist doch nicht gut.
Ich habe seit Langem
wieder mal irgendwie
einen Menschen dahinter gesehen,
einen Menschen mit Emotionen,
der geweint hat, der frustriert war
über sich selber, die Situation,
der fand, das gehe nicht.
Ich fand das kein Problem:
Du weisst jetzt, worum es geht,
vorher wusstest du es nicht.
Jetzt weisst du es.
Aufgeben ist für mich nie,
niemals ...
Offenbar.
Eigentlich war es 5 nach 12,
muss man sagen,
aber du hast irgendwie
die Zeiger umgedreht
und das als 5 vor 12 angeschaut
oder so ausgelegt,
und er hat da irgendwie eingehängt.
- Ja.
Hoffentlich habt ihr es jetzt
begriffen miteinander.
Das wäre wichtig.
- Ja, jetzt läuft es.
Nach der Scheidung meiner Eltern
sahen wir unseren Vater nur noch
am monatlichen Besuchssonntag.
Er holte uns ab
und fuhr mit uns ins Wirtshaus.
Diese 6 Std. haben wir einfach
abgesessen, neben ihm am Stammtisch.
Zu sagen hatte er uns immer weniger.
Mein Vater war ein gutmütiger Mensch,
er war nie gewalttätig.
Aber irgendwie
war er auch nie richtig da.
Er entschwand Jahr für Jahr ein
wenig mehr in seinem Alkoholnebel.
Das ist die letzte Aufnahme von ihm,
bevor er mit 47 Jahren starb.
Ich habe heute
einen Airbag ausgewechselt. - Hm.
Und ich habe ...
Ah, wissen Sie,
was verdammt geil ist?
Ich habe eine Abmachung
mit dem Chef gemacht:
Er stellt mir ein Auto zur
Verfügung, also eine Occasionskarre,
irgendeinen Schrott, was auch immer,
und daran ich könnte ich arbeiten,
alles daran machen,
ein wenig als Übung.
In der Freizeit?
- Genau. Das ist die Bedingung.
Und das wird mein erstes Auto,
das ich fahren kann.
Wow.
- Das ist verdammt geil.
Im Moment läuft es gut in der Garage.
Damit das so bleibt,
versucht Darius Omlin herauszufinden,
was der Grund für das schwierige
erste halbe Jahr war.
In so einer Situation ist v.a. das
Vertrauen zu anderen Leuten Thema.
Die Sozialpädagogen
sind immer so ein wenig Gegner,
denn sie durchsuchen einem
z.B. auch das Zimmer,
bringen das Zeug durcheinander,
machen einem das Leben schwer.
Und das ist
bei deinem Chef genau gleich.
Jetzt wirst du mit deinem Vertrauen
konfrontiert,
das du eigentlich nicht hast
gegenüber anderen.
Das heisst wieder: "Wieder ich."
Ich bin der,
der wieder das Nachsehen hat,
der, der es nicht versteht.
Logisch, oder?
Ja, ich muss lernen,
dass es doch noch Menschen
oder Erwachsene gibt,
denen ich vertrauen kann
resp. vertrauen muss.
Vom alkoholkranken Vater
wechselte Monika fast nahtlos
zu einem alkoholkranken Ehemann.
Heute ist sie geschieden und stolz
auf ihre drei erwachsenen Töchter.
Ich bin sachter geworden mit meinen
Gefühlen, mit meinen Emotionen.
Ich war ein sehr rauer Mensch.
Erst, seit ich Kinder habe,
ist es so ... weicher geworden.
Bei uns geht es halt
etwas chaotisch zu und her,
wenn alle Kinder da sind,
und dann noch die Kleinen.
Als ich noch mit meinem alkohol-
kranken Expartner zusammenlebte,
dachte ich immer,
die Kinder würden das nicht merken.
Ich weiss heute,
dass die Kinder das spüren.
Die merken das ganz instinktiv,
sie spüren unterschwellig,
wenn Spannungen da sind.
Es hat mich tief beschämt -
zuerst mal, dass ich das nicht fern-
halten konnte von meinen Kindern,
und dass meine Illusionen
zusammengebrochen sind.
Ich wollte immer das Beste
für meine Kinder.
* Leichte Klänge *
Ich bin heute persönlich sehr froh,
dass sich das nicht wiederholt
in der Biografien meiner Kinder,
dass sie es geschafft haben,
jemanden zu heiraten,
der kein Alkoholproblem hat.
Wenn ich meine Enkelkinder anschaue,
geht mir durch den Kopf ...
Ich spüre auch
eine grosse Dankbarkeit,
dass sie so frei aufwachsen dürfen.
Das macht mir mega Freude
und ich habe jeweils eine sehr
schöne Zeit mit meinen Enkelkindern.
* Leichte Klänge *
Eben
war ein neunjähriger Bub bei mir.
Er hat im Sandkasten gespielt.
Das machen Kinder sehr gerne.
Bei ihm ist aufgefallen,
dass er jedes Mal, wenn er da ist,
Gewaltszenen darstellt.
Man sieht hier das Monster,
das alle umgebracht hat.
Ich habe ihn mal gefragt,
warum er das eigentlich macht.
Er hat gesagt, das passiere
halt zu Hause auch ab und zu.
Da sagte ich ihm: "Erzähl mir
doch mal so eine Geschichte."
Eine Situation,
die zu Hause passiert war, war:
Die Mutter arbeitete in der Küche
und er machte Hausaufgaben
am Küchentisch.
Dann sei der Vater hereingekommen.
Er habe da schon gemerkt,
dass der Vater komisch gegangen sei,
komisch geschaut habe,
und dann habe der Vater mit der
Mutter plötzlich Streit angefangen.
Er habe Angst bekommen und gewusst:
"Oje, jetzt kommt wieder etwas."
Dann sei der Vater
plötzlich auf die Mutter los,
habe sie angeschrien, sei auf
sie los und habe sie abgeschlagen.
Und er sei zuerst
auf den Vater los und habe gesagt,
"Papi, hör auf, lass Mami in Ruhe!"
Und der Vater habe ihm eine gehauen.
Er habe dann Angst bekommen
und sei ins Zimmer
und habe im ersten Moment überhaupt
nicht gewusst, was er machen solle.
Ich fragte ihn: "Was denkst du,
was wäre eine Lösung?"
"Eigentlich
müsste der Superman her."
Er kam dann auch wirklich,
der Superman.
Er ging zu den Eltern
und fand eine Lösung,
indem er dem Papi sagte, er solle
aufhören und es nie mehr machen.
Für mich wurde durch die Geschichte
klar: Ich muss etwas unternehmen.
Nicht mit dem Kind arbeiten, sondern
mit der Familie, mit der Mutter.
Was kann sie machen, wenn so
eine gefährliche Situation entsteht?
Wir tauschen uns im Team über
schwierige und komplexe Fälle aus.
Etwas vom Wichtigsten
unseres Angebots ist,
dass wir mit anderen Fachstellen
vernetzt sind.
Das hilft uns natürlich, wenn es
sehr komplexe Situationen sind,
den Durchblick zu haben
und besser unterstützen zu können.
Häusliche Gewalt
ist mehrfach passiert.
Sie waren sogar schon mal
eine gewisse Zeit im Frauenhaus,
und es ist auch ein Beistand da,
das habe ich erst im Gespräch
mit der Mutter herausgefunden.
Ich habe aber eine
Schweigepflichtentbindung bekommen,
durfte also mit den anderen Stellen
reden und mich austauschen.
Ist der Kleine denn auffällig ...
Da war er ja sieben, acht  -
was wissen wir über die Schule?
Ist er da schon aufgefallen,
gab es Rückmeldungen?
Mit der Schule habe ich
jetzt erst einmal kurz telefoniert.
Sie sagten, er sei
eigentlich eher überangepasst.
* Unheimliche Klänge *
Unsere Hauptaufgabe ist es wirklich,
uns um das Kind zu kümmern.
D.h. wir sind für das Kind da,
damit es dem Kind besser geht,
und nicht für den Erwachsenen.
Das Kind darf nicht
als Therapeut gebraucht werden.
In dem Sinn sehen wir uns ein wenig
auch als Anwalt eines Kindes.
Meine Mutter
sehe ich jetzt einmal im Monat.
Ihr geht es eigentlich gut, sie
trinkt eben auch weniger als früher.
Sie trinkt zwar immer noch,
aber sie hat es im Griff, sozusagen.
* Entspannte Popmusik *
Am Wochenende bin ich meistens
entweder beim Freund oder beim Mami.
Einfach
damit ich auch unter Leuten bin,
da ich sonst schon
eigentlich immer alleine da bin.
# ... never come back.
Ich habe jetzt einen neuen Freund,
und der rappt.
Je nachdem
singe ich halt noch ein wenig.
Die Texte zu schreiben ist
eigentlich das Schwierigste dabei.
Ich brauche z.T. Tage
für einen kleinen Refrain.
# Da füehli mi dehei, wiu das Läbe
hie isch meh als nur okay.
# Chille s ganze Jahr,
vo Juni bis im Mai.
Ich gehe jetzt schon etliche Jahre
in die Selbsthilfegruppe,
und dort habe ich auch gelernt,
dass ich einen Wert habe,
dass ich wertvoll bin.
Dass ich mich ernstnehmen darf,
muss.
Erst, als mich
mit so Leuten unterhalten habe,
merkte ich plötzlich, dass es
nicht willensschwache Leute sind,
die saufen, sondern sie sind krank.
Erst da konnte ich das
annehmen als Krankheit.
Ich hatte viele Jahre Mühe damit,
ich sagte immer:
"Es hat ihnen ja niemand gesagt,
dass sie saufen müssen."
Ich merkte das erst mit den Jahren
und begann dann auch,
das anders zu sehen.
Das ist eine Lebensschule,
das zu merken,
sich die Machtlosigkeit
eingestehen zu müssen.
Es war schlimm, sagen zu müssen:
"Ich bin dem Alkohol und dem
Alkoholiker gegenüber machtlos."
Ich, die immer gerne kontrollierte,
weil ich das Gefühl hatte,
es laufe sonst alles aus dem Ruder,
ich würde ja alles zusammenhalten
und so. Ja.
Ich konnte
ausser in der Selbsthilfegruppe
mit niemandem darüber reden.
Niemand verstand es.
Da habe ich angefangen,
zu Gott zu beten.
Da merkte ich,
dass es leichter wurde.
Wenn ich
einen emotionalen Absturz habe -
das gibt es auch heute immer noch -
gehe ich damit zu Gott,
das habe ich gelernt.
Ich bete und bekomme so
wieder Kraft, um weiterzumachen.
Einfach nie aufgeben.
Was erzählst du?
Was willst du sagen?
Willst du etwas sagen?
Ja, du bist eine Gute.
Drei meiner Geschwister
sind gestorben.
Der eine Bruder mit 30
nach einer Alkohol- und Kokainparty
und der andere mit 26
an einer Überdosis Methadon.
Eine Schwester
vor etwa fünfeinhalb Jahren.
Sie war viele Jahre lang
auch drogensüchtig.
Auch Monikas Eltern
sind schon lange verstorben.
Ihr Vater hat Jahre vor seinem Tod
aufgehört zu trinken.
Es ergaben sich Gespräche
über früher,
die Monika
nie für möglich gehalten hätte.
Auch mit ihrer Mutter konnte sie sich
versöhnen, bevor diese starb.
Meine Mutter hat mir immer gesagt,
sie habe nie Kinder gewollt.
Aber sie hat acht Kinder geboren,
und das finde ich erschreckend.
Meine Mutter hatte sehr schwer
Krebs, hatte ein sehr schweres Leben
und ging ganz elendiglich
von dieser Welt.
Als ich ihr sagte,
sie habe ihr Möglichstes gemacht,
ihr Bestes gemacht, da ist sie ...
"Puh." Da konnte sie loslassen.
Da hat sie mich das erste Mal,
an das ich mich bewusst erinnere,
in den Arm genommen und gesagt:
"Ich habe dich lieb."
Ich bin froh, dass ich sie
jeden Tag im Pflegeheim besuchte,
nur schon deswegen.
So konnte ich dann
meinen Frieden schliessen.
* Leise, melancholische Klänge *
Im Sommer, drei Monate nach unserem
letzten Treffen, habe ich erfahren,
dass Magda-Lena
ihre Ausbildung abgebrochen hat.
Es war für sie wohl
alles ein wenig viel auf einmal.
Auch die Beziehung zu ihrem Freund
ging in die Brüche.
Nun ist sie
zurück im Wohnheim im Kandertal.
Wohin ihr Weg geht, ist offen.
* Lässige E-Gitarren-Klänge *
Alkohol ist ein Kulturgut.
Doch der Übergang
vom Genuss zur Sucht ist fliessend.
Das wird unterschätzt
und verharmlost.
Nicht nur zur Zeit meiner Kindheit,
auch heute noch.
Vor Jahren, während einer
persönlichen Krise, habe ich gelernt,
meinen Vater besser zu verstehen.
Es erträgt sich im Moment doch vieles
leichter nach einem Glas Wein.
Aber leider nur für den Moment.
Jede Woche mind. drei alkoholfreie
Tage, darüber wache ich akribisch.
Meine Strichliste in der Agenda
amüsiert bisweilen
meine Freundinnen und Freunde,
und auch ich schmunzle manchmal
über meine Kontrolliertheit.
So hat mich das Schicksal
meines Vaters bis heute geprägt.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Lilian Zbinden - 2020